it'll be start number eleven for antonio
sensatella here's kind of
hitting 279. this one lined
pass first and down toward that right
field corner for connor falefa
he's gonna go for two and he is in there
isaiah with a one-out double in the
first inning
so it's 1-0 garcia had a hit last night
two hops to third fuentes is there
across to crone
mr ground ball antonio senzatella gets
three of them around the double
and the rangers don't score jordan
lyle's the starter for the rangers this
evening
cj crone steps in now cleanup hitter
last night
1-1 mccrone hooks this one on the ground
over to third base
holt charging throws him out at first
it'll end the inning
this is line to left and tapia makes a
running catch
and then uh has to leave his feet
to rob joey gallo the whole time you're
tracking it but it just seems like
you're never gaining ground
until the end cobras in the batter
hitting 243.
this is going to be a great play by man
makes it what a wonderful play by
mcmahon
he got culverson by a step
brian mcmahon has played splendid
defense
gold glove caliber defense at both
second
and third numbers against texas great
numbers against the american league
mentioned last night 29
interleague home runs for chuck nasty
and that is a base hit the center field
first hit of the night for the rockies
the lead-off man aboard in the second
one out and that'll bring up garrett
hampson
that's not going to be caught live drive
to left trying to get over and cut it
off calhoun
and he does a good job of keeping that
from going to the wall
well since atella will come to bat now
old for 12 this year
0-2 pitch and he sends this one out to
center field garcia was in
that ball was spanked by senzatella but
garcia had him played well
and the sides retired no runs two hits
two left
willie grounded out in the first inning
he's all for one
and he shoots this one the other way
tapia coming on again
into a lunge and he couldn't squeeze it
he don't even know where it is
calhoun pedals to second and he's there
with a double well they'll take that
base runner now calhoun in scoring
position remember isaiah doubled
when he was up and he hits this ball
sharply into right field that's a base
hit
calhoun around third he'll score without
a throw
so kiner falafa drives in the first run
of the ball game and the rangers lead
one nothing
[Applause]
all right lyle's ready to take on
blackman here with two on and two out
bachmann in the air deep out to left
field calhoun is back and he makes the
catch at the fence
and the inning is done and by the
heron is chinny chin chin joshua fuentes
to face jordan lyles
that is fair this time fuentes
avoids the glove of brock holt and he'll
have himself a leadoff double
dom nunez to step in and slowly hit
toward
third no play and nunez hey
he got it in play and he tied up the
baseball game
spilly it's not always pretty but that
was effective
2-1 on tapia and a base hit for rymel
this could be a tweeter
rymel digging hard towards second here
he goes throw on its way
safe at second base
hustle double for rybel tapia
he only gets a double if he's running
hard out of the box which he did because
he splits the gap and left center field
infield in the 1-1 game bottom of five
and this will get the job done deep left
field
calhoun gathered in tapia looks and
puts it on cruise control comes home two
to one colorado
behind in the cat mcmahon gets the ball
to the outfield
and the rockies lead it two to one
runners at first and second and two outs
holt
hammers this one down toward the right
field corner it gets down and rolls to
the wall that will tie the game at least
gallo being waved around third he'll
score without a throw
holt's going for three and they got him
at third base
trying to stretch a double into a triple
hold his thrown out to ended but he
drives in a couple
and the rangers have taken the lead
see if rymel tapia can deliver rymel
with a double to left center field his
last time up
it would work well here looks underneath
this one the shallow center
coming hard running out can't make the
catches garcia
two-run score in the second with a fly
ball
double as tapia and the rockies lead it
four to three
what did we talk about earlier the
extreme
depth of the texas outfield
well for garcia he had to run a country
mile to go get this baseball
still out there and still pitching a
terrific ball game antonio centella
strike three he got a
huge strike out there came through with
the slider at the perfect time on
laced that outside corner if you're the
rockies
you'd much rather have garcia leading
off an inning than batting here
representing the going run a go-ahead
run and he hits this one
through into right field that's a base
hit blackman
picks it up but not before low can get
to third base and the rangers have them
cornered in the eighth
buddy coming out and he's going to make
a move
sansa is going to tap his infielders get
high fives fist bumps
job well done antonio senzatella
for carlos estevez against joey
gallo he's got him
at 98. josh fuentes double
single two runs scored
this ball driven to center field in deep
garcia going back near the wall
see you later home run josh fuentes
there's your insurance run it's five to
three colorado
and he went to the big part of the yard
too rymel with a couple of doubles
tonight
this is down the left field live
hampshire around third hampshire will
score
rondelle tapia makes it six to three
three hit night for tap get a pinch
hitter
for heim it's going to be nick solac
2-2 he's got him ball game over
rockies win it the final
6-3